atrial fibrillation is a type of
arrhythmia which is an abnormality in
the pace or force of your heartbeat if
you have atrial fibrillation the hearts
upper chambers contract in a fast
twitchy fashion resulting in an
irregular uncoordinated heartbeat your
heart is a muscular organ made up of
four chambers the right and left atria
and the right and left ventricles
during a normal heartbeat the chambers
of your heart contract and relax in a
rhythmic pattern to deliver a consistent
flow of blood throughout your body
the right atrium collects blood from the
body
and the right ventricle pumps it to the
lungs which bring oxygen to and remove
carbon dioxide from the blood
at the same time the left atrium
receives blood from the lungs
and the left ventricle pumps it out to
supply your body's tissues with oxygen
and nutrients
each heartbeat begins in the hearts
natural pacemaker called the sinoatrial
or SA node located in the wall of the
right atrium an electrical signal starts
here then spreads across both atria
causing them to contract and push blood
into the ventricles
as the atria relax the signal travels
through the atrioventricular or AV node
to the ventricular walls causing them to
contract the ventricles relax completing
one full heartbeat
immediately the SA node generates a new
electrical impulse repeating the pattern
in atrial fibrillation the electrical
signals originate from unusual locations
in the atria and nearby pulmonary veins
these abnormal signals travel through
the atria haphazardly causing the atria
to contract in a jumble of rapid Quivers
and twitches
the signals bombard the AV node causing
the ventricles to contract rapidly even
at a faster pace the ventricular
contractions cannot keep up with the
rapid atrial contractions resulting in
an uncoordinated heartbeat
after these irregular contractions the
chambers may not empty completely when
blood collects in the atria clots may
form
can flow out of your heart
through your neck
into your brain
where it can cause a stroke
blood pooling in your ventricles
deprives your body's tissues of oxygen
and nutrients if your heart is
consistently unable to pump enough blood
to meet the body's needs you can develop
heart failure
your doctor may treat your atrial
fibrillation with antiarrhythmic
medications
antiarrhythmic medications control the
electrical signals sent to your atria
which help your heart beat in a regular
rhythm
after treatment your heart may still
beat too quickly in this case your
doctor may give you beta blocker
medications to slow your heart rate down
to normal
in addition your doctor may recommend
procedures that restore your hearts
normal rhythm and rate such as
cardioversion
ablation
or pacemaker placement
an electrical cardioversion your doctor
will give your heart a shock to start a
normal heart rhythm
during ablation your surgeon will use
radio wave energy to destroy the heart
tissue generating the abnormal
electrical signals
in pacemaker placement your surgeon will
implant a small device under the skin
near your heart to regulate your heart's
rhythm